who was Santiago Duran and what secret
did he tell you JJ's father was uh at
some point he was a policeman at some
point when he was a teenager he was
working on the boats that before this
little gold mining city of Puerto
Maldonado uh grew the only way to get
supplies in was to take canoes up the
temple Potter River up to the next state
which is puno and and where the mules
would come down from the mountains with
supplies and then he'd pilot the boats
down but they didn't have Motors at that
time so he would be pulling the boat so
he was he became this physically
terrifying man and I met him when he was
in his 80s and he was still living out
in The Jungle by himself and I mean he's
seen an Anaconda eat a taper which is
the you know a cow-sized mammal in the
Amazon he'd seen uncontacted tribes face
to face he once killed an 11 foot
electric eel
opened the back of the thing's neck
removed the nerve that he says was the
source of the electric then he cut his
forearm placed that nerve into his
forearm wrapped it with a dead Toad and
claims that it would give him strength
through the rest of his life and
continued to be a jungle badass until
the day he quietly leaned back at a
barbecue and ceased to be alive
the man was incredible but the secret
that he told us was that if you want to
find
big anacondas you know if you want to
see the yakomama he was like you have to
go to the boyo the place of boas the the
place that we came to call the floating
forest and so he sent us there and it
became like this
this pilgrimage and you know in the
Amazon the a lot of the creation myths
are based around the Anaconda coming
down from the heavens and carving the
rivers across the jungle and if you look
at the Rivers it looks like that it
looks like the path of an anaconda
crawling through the jungle it's even
the right color
and so from the reference to the tribes
of women the Amazons to the Anaconda
mother everything in the Amazon is very
feminine based even the even the trees
the largest trees in the jungle the
mother of the forest the Madre De La
Selva is the K-pop tree and it's just
this monster tree these beautiful
ancient trees and that was the beginning
of the transition that we made from me
being like I hate school I want to go on
adventures you know Jane Goodall got to
do all this amazing stuff I'm just a kid
stuck here
to to eventually becoming something that
had to do with where my identity became
the jungle where my life became the
jungle the the secret that he told us
opened that door because when we started
working with these giant snakes that
started getting attention
it started getting people to go what are
you doing
um and it started it started allowing me
to have experiences that that solidified
and nailed down the fact that this
wasn't just like a weekend retreat this
was this was something that that I was
born to do and gave you more and more
motivation to go in into these Uncharted
Territory
which uh just a step back what nations
are we talking about here is there some
some geography what are we talking about
where is this so I'm in Peru yeah we're
in Peru and so which is a South American
Nation perus a South American Nation
Brazil has 60 of the Amazon which is
unfortunate because anything that
happens politically in Brazil has a
massive impact impact on the Amazon Peru
has the Western Amazon and Ecuador has a
little bit of the western Amazon and
the Western Amazon is where the Andes
Mountains
the cloud forests which is a mega
biodiverse biome falls into the Western
Amazon lowlands and so you have these
the meeting of these two incredible
biomes and that's what makes this like
superlative incredible you know glowing
moment of life on Earth so yeah we're in
Peru in the Madre de dios which is the
mother of God which I always thought was
such a beautiful
you know the jungle is the source of all
life
and uh so we were with the essay ha
people and they belong to a community
that's called infierno which is given by
the missionaries who when they tried to
go bring these people Jesus got so many
arrows shot at them they just called it
hell
um and so so Santiago Duran helped unite
these tribes that were that were sort of
scattered through the jungle and get
them status government recognized status
as indigenous people so he was sort of a
hero he was sort of a legend for a lot
of the stuff he'd done out Barefoot with
just like a rifle and a machete in the
jungle he he had died he had 19 children
and the last one the the I think the
20th child that he adopted was a refugee
from The Shining path that floated down
the river and he just took him in and
you know this is this is just a guy that
was a you know everything he did like
when he died the whole the whole the
whole region showed up it was it was he
was somebody so just the fact that I
know him gives me Street Credit like the
fact that I knew him I can go like oh I
knew Santiago and people like no
yeah yeah so you have to get integrated
to the culture to the place I mean in
every single way which is which is tough
for you for the being from from New York
yeah yeah it may it could have been
tough but it was I took to it you know
the jungle they they were very uh you
know JJ's teaching me about medicines
and we were doing bird surveys and you
know taking data on macaw populations
and JJ was just like you really want to
like he goes you gotta sleep and I was
like I only have a few weeks here I know
I don't know if I'm ever going to come
back I'm never going to sleep so we'd be
out every night looking for all the
wildlife we could I wanted to take
photos I wanted to see things and and
then you know the exchange came with
that he was like you know I'm terrified
of snakes and I said well I've always
worked with snakes I said I'll teach you
how to handle snakes and then we just
had this like little exchange and when I
left after my first time back in 2006
you know I said I said how can I help
and and they were like look you know
we're out here trying to protect this
this little island of forest that is
going to be bulldozed and and the more
people that you can bring the more
knowledge and the more awareness that
you can bring to this it'll help and so
really at that age at 18 years old I
sort of
started dabbling with the idea of that I
could be part of helping these people to
protect this place that I loved and of
course at that time that idea seemed
like too large of a dream or too large
of a of a challenge to that I could
actually impact it